the other story want to talk about that
it's affecting markets right now is in
Puerto Rico there seems to be progress
being made to stem Puerto Rico's
worsening debt crisis last night the
House passed legislation to establish a
seven-member panel to oversee the
restructuring of the US territories 70
billion dollars in debt the bill still
has we passed by the Senate which hopes
to take it up in the next few weeks so
this is the continuing saga of Puerto
Rico but I wonder Lisa are we drawing
near a conclusion here well I mean if
the Senate does pass this legislation
it's really just a new beginning right i
mean it will begin the process of
actually we're structuring their debt
and getting you know some kind of
agreement on the table and figuring out
which courts going to be handling it and
every you know all the all the details i
mean it doesn't actually give them aid
this doesn't actually give them a plan
it just gives them a path under which
Puerto Rico can restructure their
massive amount of debt which is we
should say the greatest amount of
municipal debt behind New York and
California of any state in the United in
the United States 70 billion yes yeah I
got a question about the board of
managers that is going to be constituted
because of this legislation there was an
item in there that said they can receive
gifts from the parties involved do you
is that ever had a situation where the
board of managers is going to take over
the finances can accept gifts from the
people involved in the future maybe
litigation you know the investors in the
70 billion dollars of bonds are a lot of
sophisticated institutions they are
intimately aware of and involved with
the negotiations of who's on what so you
have to imagine that there's going to be
a lot of scrutiny over this process it's
not just going to be a sort of wing it
type of approach